[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up there Monday morning welcome
to the show thank you for tuning in
happy happy Monday January 23rd it is 10
a.m in lovely Los Angeles fresh off the
plane from Tampa Bay Florida your boy
did some deep sea fishing
check that deep sea fishing we're
supposed to but the weather was too bad
so we stayed kind of along the shoreline
there
um here's the thing they don't tell you
when you do uh deep sea fishing or any
ocean fish and I grew up fishing fresh
water but when you do
um
salt water fishing in the ocean dolphins
are not your friends I didn't know this
my brother was like oh cool sweet Dolph
is the guy or uh tour guide the fishing
guide was like no this is bad see if
there's dolphins in the area they're
gonna eat all the the fish scare all the
fish away he's like so we gotta find
places where there's no Dolphins so I
caught that fish I was the only one that
caught a fish for three hours that day
nice I caught the one fish there and I
apparently you said you need to teach me
how to hold a rod yeah what should I
have done but I said also a great catch
so I made the comment positive I dig it
all right so what should I have done so
the rod it's a spinning rod yeah so
there's like a where where it's attached
to the rod let's just put it right here
like that oh not in the back oh you
meant like my grip yeah just a grip of
it was there is there any techniques for
everyone really enjoy trying to station
it like station it like here so as long
as your drag is set correctly drag is
what allows your reel to yeah to give
out a little line out there yeah so as
long as you when it's when it's actually
pulling you let it go when it stops
pulling then you lift your Rod tip up
and then reel down oh word yeah just
back and forth like that yeah but Fisher
fish are friends not food so I put them
back in the water it's a snook too it's
a snook yeah a little snook either kind
of got it I was pretty crunk too
I was hoping for a real fight but that
thing that put too much of it he wasn't
that small either no I mean snook get
huge that's a smaller snook yeah
I mean when you think ocean I was like
man we're gonna catch it we're talking
like big fish tuna Marlins he's like no
um but he was saying there's some trout
some saltwater trout there is uh that's
what he's saying around this are like
some some red red fins
not Redfin trouts I don't know he was
this dude fortunate yeah there's some of
that yeah but yeah the Dolphins are
haters dude dolphins are real fish [__]
blocks my brother's like yo this
dolphins are so sweet and he's like
trying to get him on camera I'm like
what are you doing I'll Google a picture
of a dolphin before he did you you're
just getting these shitty blurry like
fins look I go and look dolphin I'll
send that to you
but yeah it's not good when Dolphins
around so we we laughed went up the way
Dolphins like cool dude they followed us
they they don't they just just haters
man just stay on you they're beautiful
creatures but the you don't want them
around while you're fishing yeah but
something was going on because there's
an FBI and uh investigation team walking
around the waters I'm like oh they're
looking for a body for sure I've seen
way too much verse 48. it's exactly what
they're doing but uh shout out to Tampa
man one of my all right I could live in
Tampa I could definitely live in Tampa
definitely live in Tampa man
uh I I've probably I've moved to Florida
before I moved to Texas if I if I were
to move would you move to Florida
if we had to you know I wouldn't no
that's interesting I go fishing all the
time oh dude I can see why people I mean
the whole that Town's Just Fishing yeah
you know Tampa also has a deep Mafia
history too deep Mafia history yeah
you've seen that Ben Affleck movie
um forget what it's called but I watched
it on the plane it's one of my favorite
Ben Affleck movies but he he's uh was it
Jamie Renner in it no he's a mob guy
you're thinking of the town this is
called
um something night
but uh it's Ben Affleck and he's a
Boston Irish mob guy and they send him
to Tampa to run all the hooch great
movie great movie
it's in the it's an eboard City where
Live by Night great movie
and uh
it's in Ybor City where that's where the
Tampa Improv is at and that's one of the
oldest clubs in the country too
so yeah so it was filmed in Georgia
because of the tax incentives so people
in Tampa are pissed
but they just recreated Ybor City it's
just like a strip Seventh Street it's
just a strip Ybor City after 10 p.m
turns into
um neither the Living Dead it turns into
freaking
it's tough
but yeah it's gorgeous out there man
slower vibe
I feel like that fit your Vibe Jen
yeah
not really in Tampa that's more like uh
Naples and Palm Beach that's more like
there's it's a Cool vibe but it's just
like you know Florida Florida but you
know everyone's around fishing eating
fish sandwiches it's a good time good
time but uh yeah your boy caught a fish
didn't kill it though
um let's get into it though because
there were some big UFC fights going on
big UFC fights I split in the green room
I was able to tweet out live during the
fights but then also we had the fights
going on and then we also had the NFL
playoffs going on and off NFL playoffs
are popping right now if I could dream
of a super ball for me if I had to pick
with the teams remaining I'd like to be
the Bengals versus the Niners Niners my
team left in the playoffs this year
McCaffrey's my brother from another much
more athletic mother and uh I root for
the Niners right now we'll see if they
get done against the birds it's gonna be
a tough one they look [__] good
and then uh Jordan uh yeah Burroughs Joe
Burroughs has freaking uh
the chief's number so we'll see we'll
see man especially that high ankle
spring with Patrick Mahomes people think
it's a big deal I do but uh so between
the NFL playoffs TV's popping around
between NFL playoffs and then you got uh
you had UFC in Brazil going down Jamal
Hill Global Tech Sarah
the whole card in general was either
really quick finishes or just
lopsided beat downs
you know it was a good card
um
oh where do you start with this I mean
the MVPs of the night there's a few
you'd have to get to the the bonfin
twins right twins brothers are they
twins or brothers they look exactly the
same size Zoom Twins or they're just
really really identical looking brothers
that in the English language refer to as
twins but it's tough
they're just brothers they're so similar
but man what a debut now Paul Fowler got
a little zealous it was like Best debut
of all time like whoa dude get rid of
Joe Lauzon
ever of Anderson Silva you've seen big
knocks debut I mean there's some big
time debuts out there but these bro best
brother debut
probably the first Brothers I mean you
know you have the Miller Brothers you
have lows on
there's not too many brothers right I
can't remember but for them to be on the
same card my God that uh that knockout
which I hate to see it cause I'm a
Terrance McKinney fan big Tunes with
Kenny fan hate to see him go out like
that but uh that that flying detail
where McKinney reached for the leg
because he thought he was good because
he jumped with the right and you could
see was he like uh if he's at I see
McKinney's thinking that he's like all
right since that Lake's there I'm gonna
go for that one take him down but he
faked it bam I mean just walk off bam
bad bad
yeah we won't play this but yeah yeah
she's playing the highlight of The
Knockout I say you hate to see it I like
McKinney [__] happens he's a young
fighter he'll bounce back but I'm a big
fan of that dude great follow on Twitter
as well he was going hard at uh my boy
Robbie at bar stool right because yeah
because
you know when I I get it too you know
when a fighter gets knocked out and like
those sights are like glorifying it like
oh you know Flat Line like you know
almost there's a difference between
reporting the news and then poking fun
at the guy for a failure you know yeah
so it's a fine line and McKinney was
like this I don't [__] with Barstool man
what did Robbie do he posted something I
I don't I don't know exactly listen I I
you know clearly you guys know I mess
with Barstow I love Barstool and the
boys and what they represent
um it's a tricky thing when a new
company comes in
um to the UFC you know it's very it's
the the fan base takes a while for them
to warm up to and if you disrespect the
fighters a little bit or they think
you're just a basically a casual
checking in which I don't think Barstool
is but but you still don't
didn't take Robbie as a guy who would
write whole article dedicated to
disrespecting professional you scroll up
because it said see there's a problem
too but Kenny gets knocked out cold just
hours after claim Barstool did no Sports
oh so this is it says boss partial
sports but obviously this must be Robbie
writing it then yes yeah he's he's a MMA
Jam Robbie's a really good kid you just
you gotta be careful with that because
you're gonna you're gonna piss a lot of
people off which isn't necessarily
terrible because you look at that 106
retweets it depends what you're going
for
but when you you got to be careful
though because you got to realize when
you scroll back up to so it has 3.8
million views which is clearly a big
post right yeah but James McCain gets
knocked out cold so that's disrespectful
right Tim's mechanic it's not got cold
just hours after playing Barcelona no
Sports the problem with that is it's a
little disrespectful because yeah he got
knocked out cold but him getting knocked
out cold has nothing to do with him
saying barcelon to know sports but
that's you know you could argue Terrence
McKinney fired you know shots first
being you know saying oh Barstow doesn't
know Sports so they're like oh really we
just got knocked out but that it doesn't
one's a professional athlete the others
you know they're it's bar stool it's a
media Enterprise so
it you always got to be careful with
that that's why I don't like uh I don't
like really re like reposting retweeting
Knockouts of Fighters like glorifying
them like oh damn he got [__] up like
I don't get down with that because I
know how that feels I know what that
guy's going through I remember we had an
issue with someone I don't know I'm not
gonna say which team but someone would
tag the people that got knocked out in a
post and then you were upset about it I
I didn't like it either it was just like
it's just you don't tag perfect boy oh
no this is before oh yeah I don't want
to say like yeah yeah when but yeah yeah
I'm sure yeah I was just like hey oh I
know what you're talking about obviously
came in that's not what I did no yeah we
don't tag like oh check this crazy
knockout this guy got [__] up whoa
what are you that's so disrespectful a
lot of these guys are my friends too man
like don't I wouldn't want somebody to
do that to me like you know blast and
I'm like look at this guy yeah most
embarrassing moment of his life check it
out how cool fun is this it's like no
dude for you know I guess McKinney took
shots at Barstool so that's you're
dealing with you know guys you don't
fight so that's their way of getting
back at it you know it's a tough gig
it's tough gig but for Robbie you gotta
be careful disrespecting the fighters a
little bit there you know mckenney's not
a huge Dame right now but he'll get
there man it gets talented yeah and he
has you know he has not only easy Talent
inside the Octon he's also a fun follow
entertaining dude great story he checks
a lot of boxes man
and look look at this no hard feelings I
was off and he was sharp it happens on
to the next one so he took shots
together afterwards yeah it's great
that's cool
and that knee like that could it's not
like you got outclassed she could it
should happen yep it's MMA it's the
worst sport to bet on let's take a
little break from me talking about this
fisticuffs going on the slap League baby
uh Springfield Missouri I will see you
next week February 4th and 5th two shows
Friday two shows Saturday Springfield
Missouri now I'm off the Naples Florida
and I think that is what is that
February 16th and 18th Naples Florida
then one night in Bakersfield California
February 23rd that thing is almost sold
out one night one show only in
Bakersfield California February 16th
18th I'm in Naples Florida and then in
February please scroll up chin February
3rd and 4th Springfield Missouri so come
get some Springfield Missouri you're up
baby I think that thick boy.com this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by my friends at DraftKings four NFL
teams remain two Conference Championship
games only a few more shots went big on
the playoffs with draftking Sportsbook
an official sports betting part of the
NFL counting down to Super Bowl 57 new
customers can bet just five dollars and
get 200 in free bets instantly not a new
customer you can feel the wow you can
feel the conference Championship Thrills
with stepped up same game parlays take a
shot at an even bigger NFL payout and
boost your winnings with each leg you
add up to 100 percent listen you got
Scentsy you got the Chiefs you got
burrow Mahomes Joe Burroughs owns my
homes and I'm rooting for cinti I want a
Scentsy verse 49er Super Bowl baby the
49ers have been telling you for a hot
second once Samuel Bosa Natalia
McCaffrey Purdy's a beast once they're
all moving I think they can get done
against the birds I'm taking the Niners
and Cincy I think they're both dogs I
was root for the dog so get you some
let's go Niners download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use the code shop
show schab show new customers can bet
five dollars on the conference
Championship and get 200 in free bets
instantly only at draftking Sportsbook
with code shop show minimum age
eligibility restriction Supply see show
notes for details January is coming to
an end but listen if you want to get in
on on its new sale the all-new you sell
you better hurry up and get on it that's
right my friends are on it are doing
something special January to get your
new year started on the right foot
throughout January get 20 off
supplements and nutrition temp soft
Fitness 50 digital items it also means
Alpha brains in there the best nootropic
on the planet or you can pick up at
Walmart but right now save 10 percent
when you use audit.com you save 10 off
the entire site even the things I didn't
just tell you about you saved Tim stuff
everything will go on it.com shop
streaming Fitness at home fitness
kettlebells steel Club mace battle ropes
fish oil krill oil protein powders
Warrior bars they got it all for you
guys they're also doing this cool thing
the new all you on it six challenge a
six-week workout lifestyle program with
over thirty six thousand dollars in
prize money up for grabs the challenge
helps you connect with others on a
community so you can support each other
keep each other accountable achieve your
goals do it together and win money like
36 Grand in the process that's on it.com
temps off the entire site with the best
supplements on planet Earth now let's
get back to the program speaking of
betting I told everyone and their mom
that I knew to bet on I was like my lock
to the weekend it's not the Eagles it's
not the Niners it's not the Chiefs right
uh it's not the Bengals it's uh a fight
this weekend Paul Craig over Johnny
Walker you get Paul Craig's resume you
know he's Beat the Champ and Jamal Hill
he's been a lot of good guys face tough
competition Johnny Walkers Jitsu is not
great I'm always a little I always doubt
a little bit where Johnny Walker's
headspace is at you know it's in Brazil
there's a lot lot of pressure there I
like Paul Craig I said he's my lock
Jesus Christ
that's MMA dude yeah you never know
reach for that single just gets his head
beating you're like okay well [__] like
Paul Craig's a Savage dude he's being a
lot of good guys I just looked at his
resume the matchup I mean there's a
reason why they had him as a dog but
still man I just I was like yes if you
want to make money that's the bet so my
my brother's uh wife to bet on it she's
a big better really she takes my brother
and she's like why would Brendan do this
to us I was like hey man if it's for
sure I bet my life saving that I would
never bet that much by an MMA it [__]
happens you never know what you're gonna
get
uh so Johnny Walker looked pretty good
and he said Jon Jones I'm coming for you
I was like that's okay he's a
heavyweight I know let's focus on just
getting on track on light heavy weight
but he's got on track there
um so that fight was good the Jessica
and Josh Lauren Murphy again these are
you're talking about shout outs you know
what I'm saying that was my only issue
with the card quick knockout which is
great finish highlight finish or they're
just lopsided where you just like come
on you want the fight to hurry up like
there's no way this is coming like
Lauren Murphy's skill set in that fight
no disrespect at all just gone Josh it's
just not there so the chance of like a
Hail Mary like a big bomb you know at
Women's flyweight it's really not going
to happen the chance of her having the
skill set to submit a Jessica Andre it's
not great so it's just like this
lopsided you know fight it's like
watching college football went 60-0 in
the second quarter like all right I'm
good is there any way we can just go to
another game and ABC or Aspen well good
another game like we get it when
fighting we got to just stick through it
Laura Murphy you know God bless her so
God I'm tough man Jesus Christ
um then Gilbert Burns you know
I love Neil magni on for complete
nightmare of a matchup for him you know
jiu-jitsu's his Achilles heels at a high
level yeah it's tough tough then Gilbert
burning gets I'm like first of all
Gilbert Burns is that head and shoulders
what is that man using for that his hair
is a pain my God no that little like
Brazilian afro he gets going on he's
putting the acai in his hair that [__]
is glorious my God man he looks like a
uh like one of the other news channels
on Anchorman 2. it's just like that
throwback like 70s look
his Mane is gorgeous how like Head and
Shoulders or someone doesn't come along
give that dude a sponsor I don't know
they don't have a picture of him with
his hair
I'll find it
maybe it's just but either way he looked
phenomenal and then called out uh called
the company
I'm down for that come to him would be a
good fight I really want Covington and
uh harms out though yeah look at this
little it's not even that right here
this is insane that's out of the shower
fresh Daddy it's like a and I mean like
the Chia pet-ish yeah
oh that's not racism but you know just
Chia Peters oh sure it's like super
thick oh yeah it is just and it's it's
the condition and shiny and man just
tight curls no dryness no broken ends
it's just fantastic yeah I mean it might
have the best here in the UFC right now
that thing is popping dude I don't know
how they're gonna get my hair sponsor
um so Gilbert looked fantastic and then
you had uh you get to the championship
fight to the co-main event and the main
event coma event brand Moreno figarito
so I went I was on stage when this fight
was going down and I had to come back
rewind it everyone's like oh they
stopped it man I poke I'm like ah damn
that's that's a bummer like yeah but
Moreno's up on the cards so then I go
back and watch I'm like that's not an
iPhone that's a punch so he closes I do
a punch and you got to be more surprised
because they show it in slow motion but
with throws his like wrists like a limp
and just like all this hits them it
looked like a thumb or like this part
like right there goes right in the eye
that's a punch that's the punch is what
made the fight stop that's fighting
nothing wrong with that I also had Bram
Moreno pitching a shutout I had him up
three nothing I think the official
scorecards had it two to one is that
right chin first round they gave to
figarito
on the official scorecards but I'm
pitching a shutout and I'm you know even
that fight didn't get stopped he's gonna
win that thing dude that what I forget
what round it was in was it the second
that that grappling exchange they had
where uh Moreno takes him down he
reverses it and then he kicks back and
then he goes right into it then figured
you get some agility like that high
level grappling man
so the uh what's that
is that the scorecards right there let's
see
you're right here that's Hill
uh figarito
yeah so they what's it so that uh two
one yeah two one I I had it three
nothing I I had a pitching a shout out
but still he was up 2-1 when they
stopped that and stopped due to a punch
that rivalry is over nothing's done set
cooked no more we don't need a fifth
fight out of that now Figaro going up to
one when we put his gloves down like no
way he's retiring that'd be such a shame
he's such a Savage because he's a 125 or
who hits like a 55 or 70 pounder he's
fantastic and he's so fast this
technique's ridiculous skills ridiculous
talent's crazy him going up to 135
absolutely the matchups there absolutely
love this idea look at his eye yeah I
love the idea him at 35. you look up the
matchups at 35 this dudes can be a
problem
I mean dude look at those fights who
wouldn't you want to see him fight out
of those guys
inverse gray San Diego like because of
his stature
um at 125. he you're gonna get top five
guy so you think about him for score Sam
Hagin who has a fight coming up against
uh our boy
um Cheeto right yeah yeah so of course
San Diego Marlon Vera be fantastic uh
marab Peter Young Shawn O'Malley
knots dude now we'll see how he looks
but I think 35 he's actually here's what
Curry say at 35 he's actually better
he's not depleting his body of all those
nutrients those the way Cuts he looked I
thought he looked awful at the weighance
and he's ready to go and talk to all
that [__] but just you're just seeing
his face he looked ill now at 35 you
don't have to cut those 10 pounds he's
gonna be a problem I'm excited to see
what he does at 35. 35 is so mother
Trucking stack bro and you add figarito
good Lord dude
good freaking Lord
our boy got a fight right go down
I think he's 13. Adrian Giannis yeah
what uh that's my guy who the [__]
do you get Rob fun yes that's what it is
right fine and he also joined only fans
recently
Adrian yanis oh what's he doing on I
guess they're trying to like
you know they don't want it to be all
about you know sexual stuff yeah so I
guess he's going to be doing a lot of
behind the scenes kind of you know just
you know sparring and training kind of
footage but it's an only fence yeah I
think there's new hire marketing team to
like get that out there because we tell
only fans like damn Adrian
yeah damn dog
oh Rock cold does it like update
oh yeah that's right
yeah they just need to try to marking
job of it as far as like Hey we're not
just here to you know it's more than
just girls sucking weiner right or guys
doing butt stuff you know
I hear Adrian Johannes I don't his name
is the only fan shirt on [__] yeah can
you tell I'm excited about my new
partnership because I had to work with
only fans to give you guys more behind
the scenes content you just give me oh
look at cat Welcome to the Club
what them feet do Adrian dog let's see
what that dick do baby how much money
you trying to make dog get that [__]
out dog
put that [__] out get them cheeks out
son just him in a thong every Monday
Monday thong I'm sure there's dudes out
there that would enjoy it probably oh
yeah you make a lot of money man just
you're selling yourself to the devil
there but hey what can you do but yeah
Brad Moreno man uh that thing's over we
don't need a fifth fight and the main
event Jamal Hill Global Tech Sarah
there's a lot of questions on Jamal
he'll go in this fight right he's ranked
number eight the light heavyweight
division
are the guys seven through you know one
could you argue that they're better more
skilled based off what we've seen them
do prior to this fight sure there's
argument there mayor Anthony Smith was
supposed to fight Jamal Hill so Jamal
he'll take this fight on a shorter
notice things usually planning for he's
also coming off Dana White condenser
series when did he come off Dana White
Contender series chin can you go to that
first Contender series champ first
Contender series champ I thought it was
gonna be sugar if you told me to be
Jamal Hill this fast would have called
you a liar but
life is crazy you never know how it's
gonna go
God yeah they don't like contention
Wikipedia yeah Dana White condensers
produces by far the biggest stars if
you're a manager I don't get how in your
right mind can go why don't you go on
The Ultimate Fighter it's like what or
just do daylight condensers
who received you know what 2019
dude so three years
so three years since on Dana White
content series three years of him
fighting these in the light heavyweight
champ of the world
and you look at his run to the title you
know there's been definitely been
tougher runs
like so he started with
um his first fight so yeah Dana White
Catera Series right he wins TKO then he
fights Darko in January 2020
um so literally almost [__] January
25th so he three years almost to the
[__] date and he's like heavyweight
champion come from Dana White
contestants which is nuts so he fights
dark Opie some decision
um they beat uh oven Saint Peru lost to
Paul Craig after that loss to Paul Craig
so he started in the UFC there's no uh
contest so he's one and one two and one
he's two and two so he's two and two in
June of 2021 June of 2021 after the last
of Paul Craig I told you to be light
heavyweight champion of the world you'd
be like dude what drugs are you taking
then he fights Jimmy crew right no you
know KO punch uh performance of the
night then he fights Johnny Walker that
was a great one KO performance of the
night they fights Thiago Santos fight
the night knocked him out and then
basically being Jimmy crew Johnny Walker
Thiago Santos then he gets Glover
now part of this is just
timing right because you had to fight
with yon and Yuri go down the way it
went and then Jan blows his shoulder out
so he has to relinquish the title and
then yeah Yuri so then that fight's like
up in the air right and then they need
to do something so then go over you know
he has one fight left and you know I can
get Glover's yawn again so then jabal
Hill steps up
they're going to be more polar opposite
so I'm not Global text era to me too as
great as clearly's had I mean Hall of
Fame first about Hall of Fame were one
of the most respected fighters to ever
do at neoc here's the shame he didn't
get to the FC in his prime you guys are
seeing you're seeing Global text here at
the tail end of his career when he
started in the UFC his fights against
Rampage Jacks and all that stuff he was
because of his Visa in Brazil he
couldn't get over here in his prime
imagine if Glover texture started and
was able to get here and then have those
work visa issues
possibly the greatest light everywhere
of all time when he fought John he
wasn't young dude he's talking about a
guy with a lot of miles on by the time
he got to the UFC and when still became
Champion still lived up to the height he
was always this Brazilian boogie man who
was Chuck Liddell's kind of protege
I mean he's fighting everybody
dude he fought Rico Rodriguez for God's
sakes
he fought Rigo Rodriguez in 2011.
then get to the UFC in 2012.
and it wasn't like a young chicken
wasn't in his prime then either because
the work visa issues we you know we got
a late start on them
but yeah phenomenal career but him and
Jamal Hill you're talking about a guy
young guy in his prime we didn't know
how good he was going to be there's like
two opposite ships sailing through the
night and finally because of just
whatever because of circumstances they
have to fight it's a perfect storm for
Jamal Hill to be a light heavyweight
champion in the world now is he the best
light heavyweight on Earth I don't know
he answered a lot of questions Saturday
night in Brazil when you think of a kid
with his experience only fighting UFC
for three years with no really huge key
wins you know for him to fight Global
techs here in Brazil five rounds a lot
of questions questions about his
grappling questions about his cardio
questions can he go five rounds
questions how is he gonna deal with the
Mac dude of being a title fight check
there's he was just this kind of you
know
um there's so many questions going this
fight he's just this unknown unproven
fighter it's like man Glover should beat
him you know but then you look you you
think how much better he got from the
dos Santos fight to this fight you know
he's been taking down before been taking
down a bunch and this fight he looks
pretty damn good he looked really good I
think he's a brown belt now so
definitely knows what he's doing down
there to Glover's level no
um now back to the question is the best
light heavyweight on the planet well
right now he is but you look at the the
remaining schedule for him and the
potential opponents coming up he gets a
little dicey but I can't say that he's
going to be outclassed by all these guys
so rackets out of there right
um due to injury yawn could be the fight
and collab is by far his toughest test
Glover's retired uh years going through
the shoulder surgery and then Jamal Hill
is your champ
you know so he lost the number nine guy
Paul Craig
um
he beat Johnny Walker at 12. so he's
beat
and then he lost Jimmy crew right so
he's beat uh
three guys who are currently ranked
one's retired in his run to the light
heavyweight title and lost to a guy
who's ranked so it's not exactly the
most impressive resume to get to the top
but that's his story man
you know it can be tough right Paul
Craig is what you like Paul Craig yes
and he beat so he beat Jimmy crew ranked
beat Johnny Walker ranked beat Santos
who's ranked at the time beat Glover
who's ranked so you know one two three
four to get there not bad
and he lost to Paul Craig who's ranked
you know strength of schedule not
terrible there's definitely been tougher
paths to the light heavyweight title
light heavyweight right now I don't care
and this is a knock on Jamal Hill I
don't care who you are Yuri whoever you
are that belt can get passed around I
think it's me so tough to defend that
belt you need a few Champions which is
insane which is great it's entertaining
but you're not getting another Jon Jones
run not happening for a long long time I
think that belting you passed around but
I think for people to write Jamal Hill
off it's kind of crazy because him for
shieri
yeah now all these fights yeri uh magmad
ankle live uh Jan blockovich uh radkic
Anthony Smith I I feel like he'd
probably be favored Anthony Smith fight
outside Anthony Smith anybody in the top
five he'll probably be another dog
defend his title which not a bad fight
to bet on because he's only getting
better he's only been doing it for three
years in the UFC think how much of a
leap he made in this Grover fight now
granted it's an older Glover Glover
couldn't find the timing the distance
can figure out the jab speed was an
issue and just got lit up but
um
see how much better he's gonna be in the
next fight so against the ankle live
yeah he's gonna be an underdog because
the Enclave wants to wrestle his ass off
yawns he's gonna be an underdog racket
Underdog Yuri Underdog Anthony Smith
probably pretty close even lines there
but it's it's tough to say oh you know I
think he's gonna lose his next fight I
don't know this kid's pretty [__]
good dude you know he's getting better
every single fight doesn't come from a
super camp either so I mean hats off to
him man it's just perfect timing took
advantage of it can't hate him for that
but I do think it's fun now because I
would like to see the Anthony Smith
fight I'd like to see the yawn fight a
lot of Sumi fights and clavnex which is
by far stuff's matchup in the top five
depending on what the FC wants to do and
again timing
but I want to count them out against
Yuri against uh anchor live against yawn
against rakik especially against Anthony
Smith he's gonna do pretty well in those
fights so it's weird to me right now
people writing them off you know it's
weird
but shout out to Jamal Hellman insane
story insane story in this raw emotion
too after he won yeah that was nice good
for him man
good dude too we have him on food truck
I'm sure we post some clips leading up
to this good good dude man
but yeah it was a fun night overall they
had a lot of shutouts and some quick
knockouts
let's take another little break here
Springfield Missouri I will see you
February 4th and 5th that is next
Thursday I'm sorry that's next Friday
Saturday February 3rd and 4th
Springfield Missouri February 3rd and
4th next Friday Saturday only the Naples
February 16th through the 18th
Bakersfield California one night one
show only February 23rd get your tickets
at thickboy.com but this isn't about my
tour the oh he thick tour this is about
the best Kratom on the planet from my
friends at happy hippo now they have all
sorts of ways that you can get trusted
Kratom Kratom is the wild west like CBD
back in the day but right now you gotta
kind of know what companies to trust and
I asked happy people to be part of my
shows because I trust happy hippo I
trust or Kratom I bring on the road with
me in the green rooms on the planes in
studio here it's all over I always have
happy hippo on me I use a little
concentration shot they have the Cherry
concentration shot they got the new
butterscotch concentration shot it's
high level Kratom one little shot boom
home boom and you're solving problems
your brain's fired up is my Limitless
pill you can save 20 off when you use
the promo code thick 23 that's thick
with three C's 23 thick 23 go to
happyhippo.com promo code thick23 you
save 20 off
forever let's use this code as many
times you want share with your friends
your aunts your uncles your boy on
Twitch whatever you want to do
thick23happyhippo.com 20 off you're
welcome now let's get back to the
program
who else got you
this is uh a look at Jamal Hill this is
kind of it went viral because Jamal
Hill's Corner put water on his head and
then I'll just show you this clip
and this should be fine but
oh crazy right yeah it's like a fruit
punch Gatorade celebration
yeah is that his blood apparently it's
Glover's blood that's what I'm thinking
yeah yeah
but that looked pretty damn crazy that's
pretty cool and then Yuri posted on his
Instagram
I'm coming
congratulations
I'm coming so he's calling out Jamal
Hill they're just saying I'm coming it
was like the end of a weird Batman movie
where like the Joker like the credits
are over and they just pop that in like
hell yeah
yeah
um yeah I think you know Yuri's a wild a
wild boy man a wild violent dude that's
a great fight I'd love to see it as long
as his shoulder's you know good by that
time hopefully yes
but again Jamal Hill's not one just to
assume he's gonna lose his belt you know
get his [__] skills man his like his
accuracy yeah and the power is insane
yeah give me a prompt for any of these
guys yeah No One's Gonna steamroll him
no one's gonna be like your crazy ankle
life is gonna be the biggest favorite
because it was wrestling yeah I was like
that
give me a problem for these guys for
sure
oh this is real quick but Jose Aldo was
inducted into the Hall of Fame they
announced it on the broadcast hell yeah
and he was like you know crying kissing
his coach and kissing his wife knowing
stuff man that's yeah that's cool and
you've seen him and uh saw him McGregor
actually buddies yes so there's a bunch
of different buddy things that happened
here yeah and he said McGregor left the
red panties on his door the night before
they fought yeah okay how funny is that
dude dude so they said that they're I
guess they're friends like they follow
each other Instagram they kind of have
dialogue on Instagram that's cool he's
like how could I hate you know people
were asking if I want a rematch I'm like
no I'm over that he's cool and then also
like why would I want to hate on this
guy he gave me the most money that I've
ever had oh you look remember Jose Aldo
one of the best to ever do it but it was
never really a household name until the
Rivalry of him and Connor Connor and him
were the perfect peanut butter and jelly
combination man you need that you need
that adversary that's in Conor brought
that out got him to the Forefront where
even if you you just ruined for Aldo
even if you didn't know who he was
you're running because you couldn't stay
in Connor you know
yeah
um all right let's just go to this real
quick this is pretty kind of
pretty uh big breaking news as well Jake
Paul Tommy Fury once again they agree to
a boxing match and it sounds like it's
going down it should if you about if
Tommy if you're a Bales
yeah god dog
so there you go I'll take Jake Paul and
under for a round same easy easiest
fight he's on his career
and where's it is it happening in like
Saudi Arabia or some [__] I think it was
Saudi Arabia yeah Saudi Arabia it's
Saudi Arabia okay yeah
uh yeah Jake Paul number four
yeah without a doubt man
all right
this is pretty crazy Valentina
chefchenko her next opponent is going to
be Alexa Grosso nice yeah and that's on
UFC 285 which is the big card that's Jon
Jones yeah and we're doing a fight
companion for that oh yeah bet you're
sweet thick ass we are
and that's what the card looks like so
far you have Jon Jones Sarah gone right
there I don't need anything else take my
money you have uh Reba's fighting you
got my boy the Great White American hope
Beau nickel you have Neil Dirk Brunson
duplicis Cody garbrandt Julio ARS uh
Julian Marquez yeah take my money just
depending I take my money
it should be a dope card for sure you
could just give me Jon Jones a bow
nickel
uh Jared Gordon who just fought Patty
Pima he's gonna fight he's gonna face
Bobby green him a tough one fight night
April 22. good for him that's a good
fight too yeah
feels like Jared Gordon even him beating
Patty I feel like him losing the way he
did it gave him more notoriety like now
everybody's rooting for because everyone
feels like he won yeah everyone feels
like he got cheated yeah so now it like
it actually I think it's gonna end up
helping him more than anything perfect
scenario for him you never want to lose
but if you're going to that's how you
want to lose
yeah
and this is another question yes he's on
that card too I don't know if he's on no
this is too uh 287 oh God but him this
is what this is like a second actual UFC
fight Raul Rose's Junior versus
Christian Rodriguez I had to look up
Christian Rodriguez and uh he's eight
and one
and then he has one loss in the UFC and
then his last
um fight joke yeah we lost decision but
that's legit eight and one Raul roses is
7-0
yeah that's what you need for I'll see
where he's at
youngster
you just want the best for that kid
youngster I mean he's killing it
um so this is just Jon Jones making a
statement about his future in the UFC so
far he said he wants to
uh Finn oh actually get a get a win over
strogan then beat Steepy miocic and
those are the two fights that he can
guarantee that he's gonna give the fans
but at that after that point he's going
to talk to the FC what what happens I'm
with him I'm with him and this what I
think happens I think Jon Jones beats
her gun he beats steepe
waits for a little bit I actually think
I told you guys you know sometimes I
know things I can't say it confirm out
here because people ask me not to but I
told you when Francis made that decision
to walk away from the UFC and turn down
the most money ever offered to uh
heavyweight champion
there he had to know there was some
guarantee in boxing I alluded to it I
knew there was
smoke where there's fire that there was
conversation of him versus Fury so the
chance of that happened are highly
likely that's why he's able to
confidently walk away from the UFC so
you saw Fury come out with that video he
wants to do him first Francis and MMA
gloves and Mike Tyson's the ref yep Mike
Tyson's probably not gonna be around
right but even that my make gloves I
don't need I'd rather just be in boxing
it should be boxing so you can be
barefooted Fury but it just shows you
Furies that's why you love him he's a
Madman he's a gypsy he just wants to
fight but for Francis you can you know
you hope he made the right choice he
made the right choice because he knows
that Fury fights actually didn't come a
few at fruition that's why things going
on there
yeah and here's the other thing back to
Jon Jones so Jon Jones beats Sarah gone
he beats Stipe and he's like and after
that I'm with him after that's like well
I'm just gonna sit around here then he
goes back to that weird kind of
cruise control was just fighting guys
just for the payday not really even for
like he's not putting his best foot
forward he can't get up for the fights
and heavyweight you can't really do that
because you're clipped you're [__] but
here you know you'd be still gone beats
deep a I think Francis fights Fury comes
back to UFC
that would be incredible and then and
then Jon Jones if it's on the on the
maybe one or two Francis fights if he
beats him then they do a rematch or vice
versa or there's a Trilogy fight there
and that's the end of Jon Jones career
phenomenal career best career of all
time yeah I mean that would make it even
bigger than if they fought right now
mm-hmm
um so remember you were mentioning uh
Francis Ghana was going to be the
highest paid heavyweight now Jon Jones's
new manager is saying that he is Jon
Jones is now that they better be and
then he's like second only to Connor I
think which is yeah
and he usually realize that John is the
goat of course so they were very open to
work with us and come to the conclusion
of putting together a fair deal the deal
we made for John makes John in the
history of the UFC the highest-paid
heavyweight athlete and overall I think
probably second highest ever to the next
Conor McGregor that's big boy money huge
one yeah
now if they including like the the
pay-per-views for Connor too I'm sure
he's probably like Incorporated yeah
he's alluding to that but I don't know
uh this was uh pretty cool to see it's
uh Jon Jones talking about
um Daniel Cormier to Sports Illustrated
I'm not competing against uh Dan Cormier
I've already beat him twice I'm really
happy for DC I love what he's done in
his life with his wrestling and
broadcasting I think he's also when a
fighter can retire use his voice
intelligence to do something that he
loves so I've got nothing but respect
for DC that's great yeah because they
had a crazy beef horrible yeah
and then when you mentioned this before
obviously uh Jose Aldo Conor McGregor
they're cool too and then this one I
thought was super cool Gilbert Burns
said he met with uh Colby he's somehow
passed Colby Covington at a poker Place
Florida poke poker room yeah and then he
was like
Colby saw him he's like waving him over
he's like oh it's on right he's he goes
this might be a fight so he walks over
to him and Kobe's like dude I'm a huge
fan just let you know I'm doing this
stuff because you know yeah
he's like King dude he's such a good
person that's who's in he's like dude
he's such a cool he was super I'm
telling he's a five rep Colby he's you
guys know him as Kobe this heel for the
UFC it's all WWE [__] he wants to be the
heel I'd be willing to bet you know I'd
have to see his bank account but if you
went to college okay if you go back
would you continue to do this heel thing
like the whole Trump stuff all those
strippers all the [__] the [__] you
talking about Brazil will you continue
to do that if you knew this was gonna be
the result being as good as a fight
because you don't need to do it now it's
the jail sonen kind of game plan there
but heavy lies the crown man it you know
it has to be exhausting for him with
social media and all that [__]
yeah but I mean despite all this
obviously Gilbert Burns still called him
out because he's like the next guy they
should get the title so yeah I mean yeah
but it's refreshing to see yeah but what
if I told you guys that's why I [__]
with Colby even Dylan danis Dylan Dan is
off camera great guys Colby I even told
Kobe dude with me you don't have to do
this man he said yeah but it's on
YouTube it's a TV show we got to do this
like Ugh
P would love you so much more if they
got to know the real Colby such a good
person good good human being dude but he
does all this other [__] you know
yeah but you'd have to look at his bank
account be like was it worth it when he
walked down the street and you get
yelled at and you told things you have
to have security
you know you don't have kids now but if
you did is it worth it dude
I'm curious what he'd say yeah should
probably get my food truck for sure
this we haven't heard for a while Sage
Northcutt
he's going to be returning to one on one
on Prime video ten after four years of
not fighting and he's fighting a guy
named Ahmed
oh [__] that's where my first fight ever
was at first First Bank Center in
Broomfield
yeah so I looked up the other guy's uh
record he's pretty legit ten and two
um the last two fights he won yeah Sage
Jones got just came at a bad time when
when they were just throwing guys to the
[__] wolves now they realize you
can't do that you're killing your stars
so you see what they do with Patty
pimlet see what they're doing sugar shot
they should have done the same thing
with sage they just threw him to the
[__] wolves even with him you know
when he fought [__]
um
nobody's looking out for him
he should have been fighting Brian
barbarina Schumann find Mickey Gall you
know he's just not there yet and it
[__] your career the the your memory
career is a marathon not Sprint they put
him in that sprinting Lane he got [__]
with
but even at one Championship dude Cosmo
what are we doing I know that was wolf
last kickboxer [__] them up dude
destroyed his face in 30 seconds
yeah well another thing smart kid I
think he was an engineer major at
[__] text A M you left that to fight
Cosmo Alexander you get knocked out in
30 seconds the [__] we doing
yeah
a lot of damage in that fight
uh speaking of one I remember we talked
about this last week
um
shot tree the CEO the president of uh
one Championship said that Alistair over
him contacted them about their open
weight Muay Thai you know about or Grand
Prix that you could win a million
dollars for the grand prize and then
Alexander or who the [__] outside uh
Alistair over and posted this later on
on his Instagram it just set the record
straight I'm on a holiday in Thailand it
was invited to one FC event in Bangkok
heavy on the [__] as a fan of the sport
I always enjoyed watching some good
fights just a visitor nothing more
nothing less
so for all the people who love to spread
rumors sorry guys no gossip here I'm
dedicated to Glory Kickboxing so that is
so instead of business yeah
[Music]
but so shotri said it was complete BS
that he did contact one of the guys at
one Championship right so he doesn't
want he doesn't call uh Alistair out
for bullshitting but she doesn't need to
lie either no
um hold on I had something highlighted
here
oh here we go reach out to Rick the
senior director of competition to be
very specific and then they asked me
should we let over him come I said sure
So that's how it happened I don't mean
to make ouster look bad but no Alistair
we did not invite you I'm only reacting
to social media posts we did not invite
him and then that's apparently Alistair
sitting by himself at the event
interesting and then
yeah anyways so
um the whole thing was Alistair had
contacted them because he's interested
in you know getting being in the Grand
Prix because it's a million dollar grand
prize which is awesome he said but I was
for a little bit for him to say we've
invited him no we didn't we had no idea
it was even in Thailand yeah
I'm gonna go with Chacha on this
I dude why wouldn't you ask about a
million dollar grand prize I agree yeah
so okay what's up with this yeah but I'm
sure Glory probably heard about it and
uh what the f you'll be doing I was just
trying to say face down good for him
um
oh the power we haven't been here since
I was power slap gosh did you watch it
wait do you did you watch it oh yeah no
freaking way oh yeah on TBS
oh yeah I don't have to I don't have a
record
it is a [__] show dude ah my girl could
not stop laughing she's like this this
is real like this is real she couldn't
stop laughing it's the stupidest [__] I
can't believe we're in 2023 this thing's
on TBS I know TV
and the guys are like all out of shape
with guts and stuff you're like what the
[__] make him take the shirts off
it's not Combat Sports with that shirts
on yeah they're wearing what do you call
those the Jiu Jitsu stuff yeah they're
wearing like uh uh yeah
tight Under Armor outfits like no no
make them take their shirts off if it's
actual Combat Sports we can take shirts
off you can't because they look like
melted [__] cheese yeah dude you
watch it
to me it just if you're a fighter
you should know that Dana White is the
president UFC doesn't give a flying [__]
about your health if these guys can
invest in power slap Fight League
the only thing the only premises of this
show is to provide the most CT most
brain damage that's the problem yeah and
then they clearly get concussed and get
back up and then get slapped again I
didn't know that yeah dude come on get
up get them like
whack that's freaking terrible and then
there's one dude clearly ton of sugar in
this tank some big black dude timing on
the sugar tank he's all
um
Dan's like wow yeah and he was like and
this just goes God he goes this just
goes to show you just because you're MMA
fighter doesn't mean you're good at slap
boxing or slap fighting it's like no
that dude was like oh
he did twice the guy was hitting a piss
out of him and he's like my turn
it's like hey man you're the wrong sport
overall dude and I love the Dana I think
it's uh Mick Maynard they're back there
in the green room with the other power
slap League guys or whatever yeah yeah I
guess
dude they're back there and there's only
so many things you can say about
slapping like that first you're like all
right checks the box I'm like damn this
gin's crazy that was a hard slap and
then after like 10 I'm like oh man okay
it's a chin
man that slap was crazy like there's
nothing there's just on yeah man I gotta
slapped the [__] out of him
it's nuts and the the people
you know the the public has spoken the
thing did not go well like low views
um
and I just don't understand if I'm Dana
White and the same thing with the rock
too
you guys are good right
like what are you doing like The Rock
has this energy drink is it what are you
doing you have 50 major Motion Pictures
lined up in the next two years why are
you doing this drink for Dana it's like
dude what do you have 500 million sold
the UFC the face UFC best promoter ever
do it hat Kudos half Hut why would you
punch down and do slap fight for what
for is it a money play
what's the point are you that bored of
MMA
it just it doesn't make sense to me
who told him to do this and then to use
the UFC social media to promote it
that's the stuff I was looking at here
that was honestly I just think it sets
the sport back because
if if you've been a fan you're like God
this is stupid if you're a new fan
you're kind of like oh this is so
barbaric this is stupid it just sets the
sport back that they've worked how long
how many years has the UFC UFC brass and
the staff that's been there for years
and the fighters involved who've
literally risked their health their
well-being their brains they've moved
their sport how far down the field and
then to Market to this slap finding it
goes all the way back because now these
politicians or the other people are just
getting the sport go oh my God that's I
mean that takes no skill let's just
they're just slapping each other just
big out of shape dude slapping each
other yeah so all this work you've done
this just proves to me we're not a major
sport we're not a top five major sport
if you've done all this work to move the
football down the field and then you go
all the way back and restart
it's like yeah that's human [__]
fighting
that's amazing legit Professor athletes
some of the best athletes toughest
athletes in the world toughest job
toughest gig in the world but when you
associate it with hands fighting
slapping the [__] you want to call it we
go all the way back yeah there's no way
that thing's on it like I would love to
do a companion for the championship it's
so ridiculous and hilarious I'd love to
get some comics and Fighters together do
a fight campaign for the championship I
don't think it's gonna make it then I
don't think it's beyond that long
and hey Fighters out there
when you watch this think about this Las
Vegas Commission
sanctions this
you think Dana the commission of Las
Vegas anyone that's supposed to be in
charge of your health gives a flying
[__] about your health
they commissioned human slap fighting
you out of your mind and for Dana like
that's your boss man
he's sanctions thing he's the face of it
he's the one that brought this to the
table
a man who's going to do that you think
he is a [__] about your well-being when
you retire from the UFC this guy's
trying to squeeze every dime he can out
of human [__] fighting they're slapping
each other
he's putting all his resources that he's
worked all this time for all his hard
work all dedication he's pissing it down
the toilet to make a buck on SLAP
fighting now let me ask something you
think Dana White actually considers slap
fighting a sport you think Dana White's
actually really really passionate about
two human beings slapping each other no
it's his new puppy it's a new project
something for him to do because he's
clearly bored as [__] with the UFC
so this is his next conquest and it's
[__] stupid for guys made so much
money who's supposed to be so smart the
best promoter we've ever seen Combat
Sports probably one of the best
promoters the best uh Professor Sports
uh presidents
how the in the world are you so [__]
stupid it's insane to me
I watched it just for the
car wreck car wreck it's like when I
turn on the world star when like check
out a shooting like I I gotta see it
but I'm going oh my God I got it man
this technique when he slapped his
girlfriend that [__] was they should
they should hear this on TBS every night
I would assume with the backlash they're
receiving it there's no I would be very
surprised if it makes it all eight weeks
of the championship I'd be very
surprised if we're doing a fight
companion on TBS
I think he's gonna have to go to UFC
Fight Pass
I can't imagine the last thing but just
just
just look at these [__] morons this
this guy from MTV like hey everybody
check out check out the slap fighting
yeah so there's a bunch of different uh
promotions for it just it's everybody's
selling their soul I know again this is
what you want you guys to realize this
is how powerful Dana White is look at
the huge names on here marketing slap
fighting look at this guy Chris Jericho
the thing that people this is with
Daniel Daniel Cormier did it D DC
Daniel Cormier how dare you he's so much
better than this but again Dana's your
boss yeah you got it yeah that's that's
what dude when I worked for Showtime I
had to promote shitty boxing some bad
Bellator fights I didn't want to do
they're paying my bills yeah you got to
do it so if this was a Showtime thing
and they're doing fight slap League you
bet your ass like you guys make sure
it's crazy it's so fun these these
athletes and these rash guards and their
tits and guts hanging on the table their
techniques insane
you'd see me doing it that's that's all
that's going on here Mario Lopez Mario
Lopez love Mario oh my gosh you think
Marlo Pat you think DC who's Bar None
top five people to ever step barefoot in
that [__] octagon you think he has
any respect for the slap Fight League
you got to do it man sucks but
yeah man is that is Mario Lopez last one
Mario's you want to hear this one
sure
all right let me refresh is there more
than I don't like you
hold on
all right pause it real quick
and now remember this slap Fight League
the brain trauma clearly blame drop the
one girl got slapped so hard she did a
flip she fell down did a flip yep
it was so and no one held her no they
just let her go like what my favorite is
to see like uh uh what's the name uh
Herzog like legit refs be like all right
left or right hand right hand 7 15. 15
seconds blue like
hey here Zog take it easy and you can
tell even they're nervous they're like
what the [__] am I like what did they
get some on TBS
get out of each other I know I do power
slap road to the title premieres tonight
on TBS shout out to my boy Dana White
and listen if you don't know now you
know check it out no I don't know
no I don't know tell me what I should
know
out of all the [__] to invest your money
in for Dana it's like dude you've
literally worked your ass off and God
bless you man you're the perfect guy for
the job you took the UFC as far as it
could go and then you wipe all that [__]
out and do that
this would be like Celine Dion doing
only fans like what what you're set
keep singing she's like no I'm sick of
singing man I'm gonna suck some dick on
only fans like oh my God you've ruined
your career
why
I I don't get it I don't I don't get it
and also it's been around forever
Russians have been doing this for
[__] ever they do medieval fighting
they do slap they've been slapping the
[__] out of each other forever this
isn't new this has been around in the
90s has gone on this is nothing new Dana
didn't reinvent the wheel here stop
fighting has been around forever what's
next Dana arm wrestling there's more
technique in arm wrestling
ask Sylvester Stallone over the top 80s
movie check it out it's truck driver
badass
there's more technique in arm wrestling
than slap fighting
but how if I'm a dude if I'm a fighter
I'm so I should be soaking I don't know
what the [__] it's gonna take for you
guys to realize you better get yours
when you're in there man [__] hold
out for the most money possible this is
why Francis [__] left
nobody gives a flying [__] about you
guys especially not the bald guy who's
writing your checks who is doing
everything in his power to make slapping
people
popular
it's nuts to me
nuts there's no way that's on TBS
there's the championship stuff I hope it
is because we do a campaign I'd be very
surprised the backlash that they got
nuts they might make it to the
championship but then I think it's gone
after that there's there's like we're
good we're good we're just gonna keep
playing uh [__] uh Ninja Warrior yeah
that's just insane it's it's my in 2023
for the commission to sanction that
it makes no sense and you think they
give a [__] about football players
the Nevada athletic State commission is
supposed to be in charge of Fighters
Health we're like hell yeah dude that
looks healthy in what respect is that
healthy I would love to hear it
different than fine different the goal
of fighting is to hit and not get hit in
that
hobby the goal is to get hit and take it
figure it out
this doctor PhD said this is so sad note
the fencing posture when the first brain
injury he may never be the same TBS
Network should be a shame pure
exploitation what's next who can survive
the stabbing things like can I make
money on that
so this guy he got we can't show the
video but he got jacked up and the way
his his posture was like but he's saying
yeah the way it is it's like that that's
a sign of potentially you know brain
damage how about the [__] girl he had
slapped so hard with the girl was pretty
hot you'd slap silly does a [__] flip
this guy's founding CEO of concussion LF
neuroscientists
former WWE Superstar too fighting to NCT
and concussion safety out compromise
well where were you
anything crazy like
just a week before this [__] slap
Fight League aired right before that
we're all worried about Hamlin right
well safety of everybody oh my God
and then Dan's like yeah you guys worry
about safety I know I just saw my wife
check this new Fight League out
what yeah how is PR team and all that
stuff is like dude now's not the time
how in their Monday morning marketing
question I'm just listen I know I got a
post for you and do all the slap fight
stuff which I don't know if you see the
comments fans [__] hate just started
on your own but you're you know it's
your business
um real quick how much money do you need
are you not set
or you can do a crypto scheme next like
what are we doing why are you doing this
why are we doing this
I I don't get it fear Him why do it I
don't know either it's such a
that's terrible
uh so this is sort of related to that
some ex-employees of the UFC
they're they're telling this uh was it
front
hold on one second
I think front office sports are
something they were telling this uh
website or whatever it doesn't matter
like uh yeah so basically they're saying
how why he doesn't get sanctioned for
him slapping his wife why why he's you
know powerful
so this is some of the things those
inside knew nothing was going to happen
I think we all caught that Dan is that
powerful
any other sport Elite president's wife
would lead to immediate action it's
hadn't discussed at the same time he
convinced Ari that his the secret sauce
Endeavor thinks that there's nobody but
Daniel can run the UFC Daniel will tip a
doorman a thousand hotel but if anyone
comes to his office asks for a raise
that pisses him off it's so bizarre to
Dana money is love is not seen as an
instrument to buy goods or services if
you're asking for money it means you
don't love him it's very primitive
yeah so these are insiders essentially
apparently
saying that
yeah
there has to be something going on you
just something's going on there and I
love like the big like shakers and
movers in the UFC people we all know
can't say [__] because they work for the
UFC
it's just so corrupted it's
it's nuts
it's not anybody else
if that was me
Brenda and you caught me on video
slapping my wife and then I was the face
of the slap League
what what would happen on the internet
what would happen to my life
yep
um all right moving past that this is
Demetrius Johnson talking about how much
money he made in the UFC apparently he
didn't get paid uh pay-per-view points
for a while he was a little off on this
though I I saw someone uh jumped into I
was like he actually he was a little off
on the numbers now granted I think the
only one was like 130 130 for you know
the pound for pound champ at the time he
said so when I fought Donna Cruz for the
band time I was fighting for 14k to show
14 to win lost the Dominic Cruz I made
14k then I was about to fight Eddie
weinland but that didn't go through so I
thought Ian would call in Australia I
was still on that same contract and then
I got a new contract when I fought Ian
for a second time I think I got bumped
up 20 and 20.
95 uh Joey benavida shout out to Joey uh
was still on a 20 20K and 20K when I
thought John dots on my 23 and 23 uh
John Moraga 2626 Joey again 30 and 30. I
finally got a new contracts Champion I
think it was 125 and 50k but didn't get
pay-per-view points
[Music]
um
if you guys already does 2.1 million
buys you just do the [__] math you
can make a shitload of money
yeah that's tough because at that weight
class especially back then there wasn't
a huge demand
it's tough
yeah but I mean that isn't all Champions
aren't all Champions supposed to get
that pay-per-view cut
it's kind of weird that he didn't get
his well you don't get it being the
champion one time I think you have to
defend that like there's a there's some
some weird language in the contract like
you can't you just don't become like
Jamal Hill's not getting pay-per-view
points now so here just kidding
Champions next one he won't so it's DJ
talking about the UFC contract he was
stuck making 30 and 30 in his third
title defense yeah I don't know what's
going on there but that's also a while
ago yeah somebody changed
he said he was I'm going on my seventh
or eighth title defense you got CM Punk
over here and he's making 500k in the
second final you'll see that's where the
chip on my shoulder came from
yeah that's pretty [__] insane but
how much more famous how many more pages
it's a business yeah that's the thing
UFC's going people aren't buying to
watch a 125 pound guy destroy people CM
Punk has a huge fan base we can actually
do the math at low estimates he brings
in this much that's why I put in 500k
yeah and people want to [__] on CM Punk
for that but if you're seeing Punk
you know I have no business being here
what do you want me to do so I don't get
mad seeing Punk
yeah what else you got
so Greg Hardy's supposed to make his
debut at bkfc it's gonna be a problem in
that February 17th but no opponent so
far but February 7th poor Soul's gonna
sign up to fight Greg Carter bare
knuckle
tough gig yeah
this is Sean Strickland oh I love this I
threw this out I'd pay to see this
so this guy he's a viral star because of
his uh tactical whatever defense
training stuff but then a lot of people
call him fake
but this is John Strickland with him at
a gun shop well I will say this don't
say well twice uh well I will say that
felt mildly uncomfortable but I think I
should start a self-defense program what
should I call it last time I get invited
to any events thanks for having me at
the gun store yeah Sean strigan does not
play your [__] like he was not the
for this self-defense guy like if you
are like a a gimmick Chun trick is not
the guy to invite to to play ball with
you Sean Strickland has a no [__]
meter he just you know he's Savage man
let me see this I'm gonna come here
[Music]
dropped this huge entire glass but then
apparently that have you seen this that
guy talked [__] about Sean Strickland oh
really oh you haven't seen this is John
Street and was like hold up that's why I
posted Sean striking was like I will fly
you out put you in whatever Hotel you
want oh that I'll put 200k that guy you
know he's talking about this guy I
thought that was a different guy no it's
this guy he's a yo I paid 200k in Castle
we'll put in the sand and if you beat me
you take that cash
he's like nobody has to be there let's
see how it goes for you that guy I'm
like you know what Shawn's chicken would
do to you dude you better come with a
gun if it's just a straight
MMA fight in the sand no we can watch
Dude I would bet all my money strong
Strickland walks back and back on
Instagram he's gonna kill you dude yeah
you have to lose all our people though
you're insane
yeah to me it's just like a gimmick
thing but I don't know if he's actually
really truly believes that he's a
an amazing self-defense guy I don't know
yeah I don't know maybe he's not very
familiar with MMA but someone I mean
literally picked any other fighter on
the roster don't invite Sean Strickland
to play ball with you if you're a
self-defense Guru
it's hilarious it is
I saw this sparring footage recently
from Luke rockhold and um so he posts
here we still hear it's comeback season
so alluding to the fact that he might be
coming this person I took the words out
of my mouth rockhold verse till is the
fight to make 110 that's actually really
good great fight both need to win you
know both you know they're famous but
they both need to win yeah
loser leaves perfect for both their
timing yeah this is MVP Michael Venom
page he just posted a couple old videos
of him doing karate they're pretty dope
so I'll just play for you yeah
play sound and then he just starts break
dancing after that but that guy's like
distracted
yeah Jesus Christ I think he just starts
break dancing
you're not embarrassing that'd be if
you're that guy just starts break
dancing that was a Savage knockout
it says night since 19 so I guess he's
19 years old here
or maybe 2019 I don't know
but yeah that's crazy
then he had this one where he does like
a hurricane kick
he's in the black all black
hurricane kicked oh you'll see him flip
right here watch
right there whoosh I guess
athletic yeah
Jesus Christ that's it dude there's no
uh that was fun though no fights coming
up that was fun that's it kids that is
it hopefully you enjoyed the show shout
out to Jamal Hill the light heavyweight
champion of the world shout out to Brian
Moreno closing that
quadruple fight uh series
um fun time man shout out to Sean
Strickland for beating up that
self-defense Guru and hope you guys do
fight in the desert and definitely I
will pay for that or if there can be
fans I will fly out there for that
um but on tour shout out to Tampa thanks
for the great time thanks for coming out
to the shows uh next time I'll be around
doing spots around La all this week and
next week but I'm in Springfield
Missouri February 3rd and 4th that's
Friday Saturday only Springfield
Missouri and I'm back in Florida Naples
Florida when we do some fishing out
there chin if you want to come yeah
Naples Florida February 16th through the
18th Bakersfield is one night only that
thing's almost sold out Bakersfield
California February 23rd Bakersfield
shout out to Corn they're from
Bakersfield
um and then Oklahoma City is March 9th
of 11th uh we're gonna have to uh redo
Bray I think right now we have just the
March 3rd that's a Friday but um we'll
see if that happens I'll have to
campaign for that but the fourth we have
a companion but you have Oklahoma City
March 9th through 11th to come on March
23rd through 25th but get your ticket
Springfield Missouri never been there
come on out kids the Naples Florida come
on out Bakersfield February 23rd one
show only come on out that's it get that
sweet award-winning thick nectar at
thick boy.com we have new merch dropping
as well so uh everything you need to
take boy.com all right kids Thanks for
liking watching please like subscribe
let's keep it going 2023 if you haven't
checked out yet the John annik food
truck Diaries one of my favorite one is
available right now uh John's one of my
favorites so go check it out right now
on thick boy YouTube uh John ack food
diary and that's it love you guys
Springfield Missouri see you next uh
Friday and Saturday
be safe be nice to each other I'm out